ولان مشاهدينا كمان فقره وقفه مع الحدث مع
خالد الغرابلي خالد اهلا بك ومساء الخير
مرحبا خالد لهجه بيدن بدات مهادنه مع
شيجين كينج ما السبب اللهجه والسلوك ايضا
لننظر الى كيف جرت عمليه السلام بين
الرئيسين سنرى الرئيس الامريكي وهو الذي
يبادر برفع اليد والتوجه الى رئيس الصيني
وكيف صافحه بحراره وبابتسامه عريضه رغم ان
ايضا عندما وصل الى الحكم في العالم ما
بين عالم حر يدافع عن قيم حقوق الانسان
وعلم اخر لا يهتم كثيرا بهذا الحقوق وكانت
الصين على الضفه الاخرى من هذا التقسيم
ومع ذلك نرى رئيس الامريكي اليوم وهو
مبتسم حتى
الرئيس الصيني
في مد اليد وهو ينتظر كما لو كان هو صاحب
الدار صاحب رغم ان اللقاء في بالي وليس في
بكين
والمهاجره ان اردت والرغبه في تلطيف
الاجواء لم تكن فقط في الصوره والافعال في
الكلمات والتصريحات المواقف المعلنه ايضا
عندما يقول الرئيس الامريكي همم سنعرض اي
موقف احادي فيما يخص تايوان همم هذا معناه
اننا لن نقبل منكم كصين ان تفرضوا ضم
تايوان الى الصين هذا صحيح لكنه لم يقل
كيف سنعارض لم يقول لم يقل ثنا اقوم
بتوفير الحمايه العسكريه لتايوان كما سبق
واعلنا في مواقف سابقه واستخدام كلمات
دبلوماسيه فقط سنعرض اي اجراءات احاديه
هذا نوع من محاوله لارضاء جانب الصيني وفي
نفس الوقت هي تطبق ايضا على جانب
التايواني اي ان انا لن نقبل ان تقوم
تايوان بالاستقلال عن الصين هكذا وحدها
الا بالتنسيق مع بكين وبالتالي نحن مع
السياسه الصين الواحده وهذا الكلام يعجب
الصينيين كثيرا هناك رغبه امريكيه همم
بعدم اغضاب الصين لماذا لان الولايات
المتحده لا تريد صراع مع ثاني اقتصاد في
العالم مع ثاني انفاق عسكري في العالم مثل
هذا الصراع
ستكون له تداعيات على الصين على الولايات
المتحده على العالم اجمع سيكون هناك فوضى
حكيم والولايات المتحده لا ترغب في هذه
الفوضى ثانيا الوقت المتحده تريد ان تلقي
همم الصين في احضار روسيا تريد افساد هذا
المحور الروسي الصيني وابعاد الصيني اذا
هي من جهه تحاول استنزاف القوات الروسيه
في اوكرانيا كما قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ومن جاء اخرى تتعامل مع الصين كم منافس
وليس ك- جهه تتصارع معها ولكن كم منافس
وبالتالي تريد اضعاف هذا المحور لكن ال-
ال- ال- ال- ال- السياسيين الامريكيين
يعلمون جيدا ان هذا هو همم تاخير لمواجه
محتمله مع الص لانه في الاستراتيجيه الامن
القومي الامريكي التي صدرت الشهر الماضي
صنفوا الصين بانها الدوله المنافسه
الوحيده التي لها الرغبه والقدره
المتزايده ان كانت قدره عسكريه او
تكنولوجيه او اقتصاديه او دبلوماسيه لكي
تنافس الولايات المتحده ولها رغبه في
رياده العالم والولايات المتحده تريد
الاحتفاظ برياضه العالم يعني هناك على
المدى البعيد تضارب في المصالح واحدى
الدولتين هي التي ستقود العالم وهنا ستكون
مواجهه اي نوع من المواجهه هذا شيء اخر
لكن المواجهه محتومه ومن هنا همم
الامريكيون يقولون علينا تقويه اقتصادنا
زياده قدرت تنافسيه تقويه قدراتنا
العسكريه همم دعم تشكيل شبكه من الحلفاء
وشركاء بهدف مشترك مواجهه النفوس الصيني
ومواجهه النفوذ الصيني نتنافس مع على
المستوى الدولي للحد من النفوذها على
المستوى الدولي وهذه هي استراتيجيه
امريكيه لمواجهه الصين لاحقا على امل
ابعاد المواجهه وان تكون هذه المواجهه في
ظل في اطار التنافس وليست بالضروره في
اطار صراع مسلحه وبالحديث عن هذه المواجهه
المحتمله اييه في المقابله الرئيس الصيني
تحدث عن خطوط حمراء في العلاقه ما بين
البلدي كلمات تكاد تكون بعيده عن
دبلوماسيه تايوان خط احمر تايوان هي جوهر
المصالح الصينيه وهي اساس العلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه واستقلال تايوان هو
تهديد للسلام والامن لهذه المنطقه بكلمه
اخرى استقلال تايوان ان دعمتم استقلال
تايوان وان وصلت تايوان الى اعلان
الاستقلال هذا يعني الحرب تهديد واضح
يكاد يكون مخفي يعني من جانب الصيني راح
معنا الصين لا تريد المواجهه مع الولايات
المتحده وهي لا تريد ان تتحدها ربما لا
تريد ان تتحدها الان لكن ما تفعله الصين
هي انها تستعد ان تتحداها في يوم ما تفعله
الصين هي كحافر الانفاق لا تريد ان يراها
احد او يسمع بها احد لكن تعمل لكي تبقى
مصنع العالم
تغزو العالم باقتصادها ومن غير من خلال
انتشار الاقتصادي يصبح لها نفوذ سياسه على
دول التي تنتشر فيها وتجني المصالح
الاقتصاديه التي تسمح لها بتطوير
القدرات العسكريه التي تحمي ايضا المصالح
الاقتصاديه لكي تتقدم الصين وتصل الى
اللحظه التي تراها مناسبه لتتحدى الولايات
المتحده هي لا تريد ان تتحدث الان لان
الوقت ليس هو الوقت المناسب ربما ومن هنا
هي تبتعد لكن من الواضح ان الرساله انه
حتى لم تكن لدينا رغبه في مواجهه الولايات
المتحده موضوع ممكن ان يفجر الامور لكن
واضح ان هناك رغبه من الطرفين الان في
تجميد هذا الملف والابتعاد عن موضوع
المواجهه التعاون في بعض الملفات لكن الكل
الطرفان يعلمان جيدا ان هناك مواجهه في
لحظه ما ستتم والامريكيون يستعدون لها
والصينيون بدورهم يستعيدون لها وعندما
تكون الصين هي ايضا مستعد عندها ستختارها
كيف سيكون نوع هذه المواجهه شكرا جزيلا لك
خالد الغرابي كنتم على خير فقره واقفه مع
الحدث